SPEAKER: You've got a great
idea for the next big app,
and you're just
itching to get started.
You want a development
platform that's easy to use,
and you want to make sure
it's going to scale up
with you after you make it big.
You want to pick the language
you're most comfortable with.
And of course, you don't want to
think too much about monitoring
and operations.
Well, it's time to check
out Google App Engine.
App Engine is a managed
application platform
that supports any
language, framework,
or library you want to use.
We worry about the
infrastructure,
so you can focus on your code.
You can get started today with
Node.js, Ruby, PHP, Go, Java,
Python, or even .NET.
And if that's not enough,
you can bring your own custom
container using any programming
language or library.
When you're ready to
deploy to the cloud,
just run gcloud app deploy.
App Engine will take care
of uploading your code
and running it on
Google's infrastructure.
For Java or .NET
lovers out there,
we have great integration
with Eclipse, IntelliJ,
and Visual Studio, making
it simple to get started.
When you're ready to push
updates to your application,
App Engine makes it easy.
You can run multiple
versions of your application
at the same time
and can even split
traffic between different
versions of your app,
making it simple to perform
rollouts or A/B testing.
As your application
starts to grow,
we'll automatically
scale it for you.
App Engine
automatically balances
instances of your application
across multiple availability
zones, making sure your
app is up and available.
And if your traffic
slows down, we'll
automatically scale the number
of instances back down as well.
Of course, no one
writes perfect code.
Being able to debug and
monitor applications,
even in production, is just as
important as deploying code.
App Engine integrates seamlessly
with Google Stackdriver
diagnostics.
Monitoring, logging,
debugging, tracing--
it's all available out of
the box with minimal setup
and configuration.
Running your code in the
cloud is just a start.
You need databases, caches,
scalable file storage.
And here's where the rest of
Google Cloud Platform comes in.
App Engine lets you leverage
these powerful systems
without needing to worry
about setup or infrastructure.
Our goal with App
Engine is to make
developing applications for the
cloud just a little bit easier.
You bring the code, and
we'll handle the rest.
I can't wait to see
what you'll build next.